[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
while we were fighting the fan coming on
the southern side it came in on the
eastern side while we're fighting the
eastern side it came in from the western
side don't really have too much of a
chance when that happens we open one
area where we did not expect any flames
and there was a big ball of fire that's
when we ran out and as we ran out thank
goodness the radiant heat that made the
Tsushima sort of imprints had moved
elsewhere but as I was running it was
coming back again and it must have
melted the back of my shoes
you've got all these multi Billy
as long as I'm president of the United
States Iran will never be allowed to
have a nuclear weapon good morning I'm
pleased to inform you the American
people should be extremely grateful and
happy no Americans were harmed in last
night's attack by the Iranian regime we
suffered no casualties all of our
soldiers are safe and only minimal
damage was sustained at our military
bases our great American forces are
prepared for anything
Iran appears to be standing down which
is a good thing for all parties
concerned and a very good thing for the
world
no American or Iraqi lives were lost
because of the precautions taken the
dispersal of forces and an early warning
system that worked very well I salute
the incredible skill and courage of
America's men and women in uniform for
far too long all the way back to 1979 to
be exact
nations have tolerated Iran's
destructive and destabilizing behavior
in the Middle East and beyond those days
are over
Iran has been the leading sponsor of
terrorism and their pursuit of nuclear
weapons threatens the civilized world we
will never let that happen last week we
took decisive action to stop a ruthless
terrorists from threatening American
lives at my direction the United States
military eliminated the world's top
terrorists
Kassem Soleimani as the head of the cuts
force Salamone was personally
responsible for some of the absolutely
worst atrocities he trained terrorists
armies including Hezbollah launching
terrorist strikes against civilian
targets he fueled bloody civil wars all
across the region he viciously wounded
and murdered thousands of US troops
including the planting of roadside bombs
that maim and dismembered their victims
Salah mani directed the recent attacks
on US personnel in Iraq that badly
wounded for servicemembers and killed
one American and he orchestrated the
violent assault on the US Embassy in
Baghdad in recent days he was planning
new attacks on American targets but we
stopped him solemn and his hands were
drenched in both American and Iranian
blood he should have been terminated
long ago by removing solemn a knee
we have sent a powerful message to
terrorists if you value your own life
you will not threaten the lives of our
people as we continue to evaluate
options in response to Iranian
aggression the United States will
immediately impose additional punishing
economic sanctions on the Iranian regime
these powerful sanctions will remain
until Iran changes its behavior in
recent months alone Iran se ships in
international waters fired an unprovoked
strike on Saudi Arabia and shot down two
US drones iran's hostilities
substantially increased after the
foolish Iran nuclear deal was signed in
2013 and they were given 150 billion
dollars not to mention 1.8 billion
dollars in cash
instead of saying thank you to the
United States they chanted death to
America in fact they chanted death to
America the day the agreement was signed
then Iran went on a terror spree funded
by the money from the deal and created
hell in Yemen Syria Lebanon Afghanistan
and Iraq the missiles fired last night
at us and our allies were paid for with
the funds made available by the last
administration the regime also greatly
tightened the reins on their own country
even recently killing 1,500 people at
the many protests that are taking place
all throughout Iran the very defective
jcpoa expires shortly anyway and gives
Iran a clear and quick path to nuclear
breakout Iran must abandon its nuclear
ambitions and end its support for
terrorism the time has come for the
United Kingdom Germany France Russia and
China to recognize this reality they
must now break away from the remnants of
the Iran deal or jcpoa and we must all
work together toward making a deal with
Iran that makes the world a safer and
more peaceful place we must also make a
deal that allows Iran to thrive and
prosper and take advantage of its
enormous untapped potential Iran can be
a great country peace and stability
cannot prevail in the Middle East as
long as Iran continues to foment
violence unrest hatred and war the
civilized world must send a clear and
unified message to the Iranian regime
your campaign of terror murder mayhem
will not be tolerated any longer
it will not be allowed to go forward
today I am going to ask NATO to become
much more involved in the Middle East
process over the last three years under
my leadership our economy is stronger
than ever before at America's achieved
energy independence these historic
accomplishment shades our strategic
priorities these are accomplishments
that nobody thought were possible and
options in the Middle East became
available we are now the number one
producer of oil and natural gas anywhere
in the world we are independent and we
do not need Middle East oil the American
military has been completely rebuilt
under my administration at a cost of 2.5
trillion dollars
u.s. armed forces are stronger than ever
before our missiles are big powerful
accurate lethal and fast under
construction are many hypersonic
missiles the fact that we have this
great military and equipment however
does not mean we have to use it we do
not want to use it American strength
both military and economic is the best
deterrent three months ago after
destroying 100% of Isis and its
territorial Caliphate we killed the
savage leader of Isis al Baghdadi who
was responsible for so much death
including the mass beheadings of
Christians Muslims and all who stood in
his way he was a monster al Baghdadi was
trying again to rebuild the Isis
Caliphate and failed tens of thousands
of Isis fighters have been killed or
captured during my administration Isis
is a natural enemy of Iran
the destruction of Isis is good for Iran
and we should work together on this and
other shared priorities finally to the
people and leaders of Iran we want you
to have a future and a great future one
that you deserve one of prosperity at
home and harmony with the nations of the
world the United States is ready to
embrace peace with all who seek it I
want to thank you and God bless america
thank you very much thank you thank you
[Music]
while we are fighting the front coming
on the southern side it came in on the
eastern side while we're fighting the
eastern side it came in from the western
side don't really have too much of a
chance when that happens we open one
area where we did not expect any frames
and there was a big ball of fire that's
when we would be ran out and as we ran
out thank goodness the a radiant heat
that made